[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique nous
essayons aujourd'hui de prendre un petit
peu de recul face aux violences commises
en marge des manifestations des gilets
jaunes comment lutter contre cette
violence sans mettre en péril nos
libertés individuelles
comment venir à bout des casseurs s'en
limiter le droit de manifester ou encore
faut-il interdire les lbd les fameux
lanceurs de balles de défense
voici quelques unes des questions sur
lesquelles vont débattre nous trois
invités tout d'abord céline roy ancien
gilet jaune à vesoul et maintenant
adhérente de la france insoumise le
parti de jean luc mélenchon
face à elle frédéric barbier député la
république en marge du doubs il a voté
pour la loi anti-casseurs une loi qui a
fait polémique
et puis richard divers c'est le
secrétaire départemental de la cgt pour
le département du jura
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez commenter
cette émission grâce au hashtag dit paul
fc hashtag dit mme paul fc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté
alors première question va faire déjà un
premier tour de table et je m'adresse à
avouer céline roy vous avez occupé le
rond-point de noidant le faire auprès de
vesoul
dès le début du mois dans les vesoul
près de près de vesoul dès le début du
mouvement le 17 novembre
vous avez doc était manifestante à de
nombreuses reprises est ce que vous vous
avez assisté à des violences alors nous
quelques jours après 17 novembre on a
été expulsé entre guillemets par la
gendarmerie mobile gentiment on passe
gentiment ben pas gentiment parce qu'on
était complètement pacifique sur assis
sur un rond point et on a reçu des gaz
lacrymogènes alors qu'on venait de leur
offrir des roses blanches donc
le sentiment d'injustice est à l'ancré
quand même richard divers vous comme je
disais vous êtes responsable
départemental de la cgt alors des
manifestations vous avez participé vous
en avez organisé quels sont les devoirs
que vous devez respecter en tant
qu'organisateur de manifestants
manifestation c'est à dire qu'on doit
nous on doit faire une déclaration en
préfecture
les plus grosses villes trois jours
minimum avant le avant la manifestation
et puis on donne les modalités de la
manifestation à dire les tracés le tracé
et puis les heures approximatives de
départ et de thym de fin de
manifestation vous êtes vigilant sur
quoi vous c'est la dislocation où ça
pose toujours un petit problème sur un
département jura val comme le jura on
n'a pas trop ce type de difficultés ce
qui n'est pas forcément le cas par
contre dans les grandes villes où j'ai
pu assister lors de rassemblements
nationaux des difficultés beaucoup plus
gras froid avec des drm
par exemple les anarchistes dont on a
beaucoup parlé ces dernières semaines
les extrémistes de droite des
extrémistes de gauche voulaient
craignais dans le jura vous savez sont
peu nombreux donc on a vous les
connaissez ma meillere de risso de
risques on les connaît voilà vous les
repérer vous même voilà vous faites des
fois un peu le ménage vous même dans les
manifs assez rare c'est là on arrive par
la discussion régler les choses assez
facilement frédéric barbier vous vous
êtes un ancien socialiste je pense que
vous avez fait des manifestations est ce
que vous vous avez rencontré des gilet
jaune dans votre circonscription et
comment ça s'est passé
je suis aussi un ancien syndicaliste
donc bien sûr je me suis attaché à les
rencontrer sur l'ensemble des
ronds-points et puis essaie de nouer le
contact et le dialogue et à partir de
cela j'ai engagé une visite sur les
quasiment cinquante six communes de la
4e circonscription du doubs j'ai été
associé à cette démarche et on fait
encore demain matin une réunion auquel
ils sont invités sur mais par exemple
par exemple quand vous vous étiez
syndicaliste vous aviez peur des
manifestations et que cela dégénère
n'ont jamais parce que effectivement on
était encore il ya pas longtemps sur une
manifestation hérimoncourt le cas de
peugeot
voici un site de plus
deux des rimes cours avec bien sûr les
différentes organisations syndicales ça
s'est très bien passé malgré ces
encadrée parce que si c'est organisé
s'organiser parce que c'est déclarer
comme le disait monsieur d'hiver les
hausses de départs sont prévus l'odeur
d'oeuf 1 aussi et puis un service
d'ordre pas uniquement je veux dire de
la gendarmerie mais aussi eu parfois des
organisations syndicales
c'est un droit vous vous êtes en retrait
des gilet jaune depuis le début janvier
pourquoi pas parce que j'ai été condamné
en justice justement à cause de ces
manifestations la parce que c'étaient
des manifestations no no no déclaré nous
ont autorisés à accepter pour entrave à
la circulation c'est bien ça le facteur
le chef d'inculpation dont les jeux j'ai
quand même deux mois de sursis ultime
pendant deux mois de prison fin oui
voilà donc j'ai décidé de prendre un peu
de recul mais de ça calme
c'est ça voulait dire c'est que la
répression fonctionne ça me ça calme pas
mais la répression fonctionne c'est
juste que voilà j'ai trois enfants donc
je peux pas me permettre de partir de
demain en prison comme ça et voilà mais
je garde c'est leur papa qui ferait la
tête sa défense il ya le pape a sûrement
mes enfants si c'est après je garde les
mêmes revendications je suis toujours et
que vous avez payé des amendes si j'ai
payé des amendes aussi ou sens aussi
j'ai bien noté 157 euros d'amendé 800
euros de dédommagement exactement à ça
s'ajoute aussi les frais d'avocat et
tout un tas de choses
après vous avez été aidé par une petite
cagnotte cela des mains et je tiens
encore à remercier les gens qui ont
participé
on va passer à la première partie de
cette émission à savoir les lbd les
lanceurs de balles de défense en inde a
beaucoup entendu de parler alors il
s'agit d'une arme non létale ça veut
dire qu'elle ne doit pas donner la mort
qui tire des balles de 40 mm soit 4 cm
les utilisateurs ce sont des policiers
ou des gendarmes qui sont formés pour
l'utilisation de ces armes est la
consigne c'est de viser ni la tête ni
les parties génitales et il faut être au
moins à plus de 10 mètres de haut des
des manifestants est ce que l'un d'entre
vous a déjà vu des ailes bd en action
dans sa vie en actions non non non
alors des professionnels de santé
protestent contre l'utilisation de ces
lbd c'est le cas de deux chefs de
service de l'hôpital jean minjoz de
besançon
ils ont lancé une pétition sur internet
ou écrit au président de la république
le professeur laurent thinès
neurochirurgien et bernard delbosc un
ophtalmologue demande l'interdiction des
ailes bd compte tenu de la gravité des
blessures provoquées
on les écoute on a pu constater qu'au
cours des différentes manifestations ou
ses lanceurs ont été utilisées des
lésions oculaires graves essaimant nom
particulièrement important et c'est
cette importance et là des dégâts et du
nombre de liaisons qui nous ont fait
réagir en tant que médecins spécialistes
dont l'objectif est habituellement de
préserver la vue est aussi en tant que
citoyen les conséquences sont très
importants parents très importante sur
la personne elle même sur sa vision son
activité sociale sur son activité
professionnelle
donc si ce type d'engin à des
conséquences telles on ne peut pas ne
pas réfléchir à son utilisation la
manière de s'en servir si c'est ça ce
moratoire c'est discuter arrêtez-le
usage des armes discuter des conditions
d'application très strict de ces armes
est aussi donner des solutions de
recours aux citoyens en cas de non
respect de ces consignes pour qu'ils
puissent établir une procédure qui leur
permettent d'avoir un recours en cas de
blessure
[Musique]
on va écouter maintenant jouer le
mathurin c'est le préfet du doubs il l'a
reconnu l'utilisation des lanceurs de
balles de défense des ailes bd dans le
département à montbéliard et à besançon
au moins une vingtaine de fois il
explique pourquoi quand on passe en
violences urbaines
quand il y à des jets de projectiles
acide par par boules de pétanque
on est en situation de défense des
forces de l'ordre et donc dans certaines
situations question il ya des personnes
qu'il faut neutraliser et on arrive à
2003 l bd quand vous voyez les installe
logist qui demande un moratoire sur les
ailes bd vous réagissez comme ans
écoutez moi ce que je souhaite souligner
c'est quand même il est inadmissible au
xxième siècle que nous puissions avoir
dans le doubs a déploré une douzaine de
blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre qui
ne sont là que pour protéger la
population
il est pas possible d'imaginer que dans
un état de droit on puisse laisser
saccager besançon parce que c'est ça le
sujet vous l'avez vu comme moi
les conteneurs brûlés en pleine place
pasteur qu'on puisse laisser envoyer des
boules de pétanque en contre des
policiers ou des gendarmes
il faut réagir pour maintenir l'ordre et
la paix civile
mais possible que quand la force reste à
la loi
[Musique]
céline roy est ce que vous comprenez
vous le préfet qui dit que les forces de
l'ordre doivent se défendre
je comprends totalement que les forces
de l'ordre doivent se défendre et c'est
totalement légitime nous ne sommes pas
là pour donner des coups ou en recevoir
mais ce que je comprends pas c'est quand
on dit ça sert qu'à se défendre ou à
défendre les forces de l'ordre et quand
on voit sur des centaines de vidéos qui
ont été filmés justement quand c'est le
bd ont été utilisés qu'il ya des
personnes qui ne sont liées en train de
jeter des parpaings ou des boules de
pétanque qui sont simplement en train de
manifester
pas du tout agressive et qui reçoivent 1
rbd dans l'oeil ce qui les handicaps à
vie et après ça il ya quand même à
l'impact au niveau familial ou
professionnel est ce que c'est ce que le
professeur delbosco nizet voilà il ya
quand même 35 ophtalmologue qui ont
déposé une demande de moratoire
il ya des neurochirurgiens qui
s'inquiètent sur la question il ya le nu
il ya le conseil de l'europe à un moment
donné si même l'onu et le conseil de
l'europe se met à se poursuivre sur la
question c'est que je pense qu'il ya
quand même une dérive au niveau de
l'utilisation de cette arme alors larmes
lbd a été utilisé à 14000 reprises en
france et qu'actuellement il y à 174
enquête de l'igpn
c'est l'inspection générale de la police
nationale sur des violences policières
dont à peu près 80 à propos des ailes
bds que vous partager la vie de céline
roy sur les ailes bd pour une bonne
partie oui le lait lbd sont des armes
dangereuses et mutilantes
on a d'autres possibilités d'ailleurs
dans les autres pays d'europe
on utilise autre solution que ce type
d'armé c'est quand même utilisé dans
d'autres pays d'europe comme la pologne
l'allemagne l'espagne
il n'y a pas que la france qui l'utilisa
oui mais il ya d'autres méthodes de
maintien de l'ordre qui sont utilisés
peut-être plus de distance pour éviter
justement ce contact trop de proximité
avec avec les gens qui seraient et
violent dans les manifestations parce
qu'il est quand même clair que et ça on
ne condamne que il n'est pas acceptable
qui est une atteinte qu'ils soient
portés ou personnes et aux biens
lors de mouvements sociaux quels qu'ils
soient on en a fait les frais ou si nous
la cgt sur certains mouvements plus dans
les grandes villes
et on voit d'ailleurs que c'est sûr
utilisé parce qu'on sait que ces
personnes qui interviennent sur les
manifestations
on sait qu'on les laisse passer quand
vous connaître vous dit où les laisse
passer c'est les forces de l'ordre
laisse passer les cazéens forces de
l'ordre et espacés les casseurs un
exemple concret auquel j'ai assisté c1 à
la manifestation de juin 2016 à paris
lorsque nous sommes arrivés il y avait
des pas les lois elles comrie c'était
contre les lois elles comrie voilà nice
le ministre c'est le premier ministre
c'est evans à l'époque où lorsqu'on a un
petit peu on est une camarade qui a un
petit peu titiller mais l'éléphant solo
mais vraiment gentiment les à chahuter
quoi les achats 8ème en montrant son
bras comme ça pour faire en disant je
suis costaud il a dit enfin là les gens
qui étaient là a dit on sait que c'est
pas où ils sont déjà passés puisque vous
trouvé le nom n'a pour l'heure donné on
n'a pas l'ordre de les empêcher de
passer
donc les casseurs sont laissés passer et
puis donc les ailes bd ça vous paraît
être une force inappropriée face à des
manifestants lambda tout à fait on a je
pense qu'on a les moyens d'empêcher ces
éléments violents
d'entrée dans les manifestations en
d'autant plus quand une manifestation
syndicale parce qu'on sait cadres et sas
qui régit les jaunes c'est pas ça va
laisser on va laisser répondre frédéric
barbier je sens qui ronge son frein
donc pour vous les lbd c'est trop s'est
pas assez dégoûté on en est à trois
milles plus de 3000 blessés sur le
territoire national et des gens qui vont
effectivement classiques qui sont tombés
cette semaine 2300 blessés selon le
ministère de l'intérieur
parmi les manifestants et dans les
forces de l'ordre 1500 blessés dans les
forces de l'ordre toujours selon le
ministère de l'intérieur plus 3000
blessés
autant dans les photos dans le hall que
j'allais vers l'élection sion sion
communes dont certains qui vont rester
handicapé à vie ça a été évoqué et donc
je dire le travail que nous avons devant
nous vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est effectivement comment on arrive à
revenir à ce qu'on a connu par le passé
ce que j'ai connu moi encore
dernièrement à avoir des manifestations
qui se passe effectivement dans le calme
je veux dire ça devrait pas être utilisé
c'est ce ce moyen de défense mais quand
on voit ce qui s'est passé aux
champs-elysées ne serait-ce que le
samedi dernier mais ça fait globalement
peu près depuis mi-novembre que ça dure
et il ya une exaspération d'ailleurs
dans la population qui est en train de
naître par rapport à ça il faut moi je
suis très attaché à la liberté de
manifester
c'est primordial dans une démocratie
mais il faut qu'on arrive effectivement
à revenir sur des manifestations qui
sont déclarés dans laquelle
effectivement on ne rencontre pas de
deux personnes ultra violente des
personnes qui cherchent à renverser la
république qui s'attaque à nos forces de
à nos forces de l'ordre et je veux dire
c'est l'objet de la de la loi et
j'assume totalement dérouté cette loi
oui justement la loi donc anti casseurs
qu'être qui a été surnommé comme ça elle
a été votée le 5 février à l'assemblée
nationale il ya eu 3 187 votes pour 92
contre 74 abstentions ton crâne 50
députés de votre corps de la république
en marche ses preuves que quand même ça
fait pas l'unanimité y compris dans la
majorité
j'ai manifesté je sais ce que ces
questions une manifestation qui se passe
dans de bonnes conditions et dans cette
loi vous pouvez la lire et le relire
on facilite la déclaration une seule
personne d'un des mêmes départements
suffi au pouvoir effectivement déclaré
une manifestation derrière il n'y a pas
de fous
à l'entrée des manifestations qui
pouvaient une veillée de manifestants
visage et un moment donné et puis vous
avez fait marche arrière quand vous avez
vu le tollé
il fallait faire marche arrière sur ce
sujet de façon à permettre à toutes
celles et ceux qui kiffent ceux qui
veulent manifester puisse effectivement
se rendre ce lundi et dont on va on va
faire parler donc céline roy et richard
divers vous dans cette loi anticasseurs
quelle est la mesure qui vous paraît
remettra en cause nos règles
démocratiques
alors s'il me fait doucement sourire
c'est que monsieur barbier vous dites
que vous êtes très attaché à la liberté
de manifester et vous voté pour cette
loi
pour moi qui est liberticide et kiki
meeting ne va pas du tout dans le chemin
de la liberté de manifester vous
demandez des personnes qui déclarent les
manifestations en préfecture ce que je
conçois et ce que je trouve tout à fait
normal et aussi comment voulez vous
qu'une personne déclare une
manifestation imaginons sur les champs
elysées et que ça prenne la tournure que
ça prend actuellement
ça veut dire que ça personne n'a en
assumerait les conséquences derrière y
compris les nazis d'avoir ailleurs y
compris les frais financiers exactement
est ce que vous vous prendriez ces
décisions de dire je lance une
manifestation mais je nom de votre parti
politique ou autre et je vais assumer
tous les frais qui peuvent arriver
derrière sachant que tout le monde peut
joindre à cette manifestation ont valu
ce qu'on va le faire répondre tout de
suite vous vous êtes prêt à mettre votre
nom au bas de la déclaration en
préfecture les assumer des risques
financiers lui le début qu'est ce qu'on
a demandé
on a demandé effectivement pouvoir
entrer en négociation que vous vendez
gilet jaune et personne n'est venu
négocier
qu'est ce qu'on a dit dès le début il
faut structurer que le mouvement des
gilets jaunes se structure pour éviter
ce à quoi on en train d'arriver
aujourd'hui et je poursuis je poursuis
interdiction on a mis dans cette loi
interdiction effectivement de manifester
avec le visage dissimulé casqués et
cagoulés
mais quels sont les éléments qui
infiltre le mouvement des gilets jaunes
et qui sont des éléments ultra violents
des gens qui arrivent masqués cagoulés
tous et qui effectivement sont derrière
des casseurs sur les manifestations a dû
tresser qu'est ce qu'on a fait par
ailleurs on le dit que les personnes qui
étaient ultra violente n'aurait plus le
droit de manifester tout ça pour
effectivement permettre que les
manifestations enfin ce parce qu'on veut
en vain demandé à richard d'hiver car
quel est votre avis quelle est la mesure
qui vous paraît vous antidémocratique
dans cette loi que céline roy dit
berti side déjà au départ on enlève au
juge un certain nombre d'années
d'appréciation par rapport à
effectivement un quelconque délit ou
justice a indiqué que jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant c'était pas possible mais
maintenant le préfet peut dire à
quelqu'un attention vous ne pouvez pas
manifester aujourd'hui et il peut même
donc le placer en garde à vue c'est ça
qui vous embête c'est tout à fait ça
c'est à dire qu'on est en train de faire
glisser de plus en plus vers les forces
de l'ordre le pouvoir un pouvoir qui ne
devrait pas relever leur niveau et on
voit que au fil des années et des
gouvernements
on se saisit de mouvements qui sont
certainement parce qu'il ya des
violences mais qui sont quelquefois
aussi laissé qu'on laisse faire pour
s'en servir comme prétexte pour ne pas
répondre aux réponses d'urgence sociale
qui peut qui peuvent être posées pour
axer la clé on va faire répondre les
députés de la république en marche qui
est venu exprès pour ça vous laisser
passer les casseurs pour que ce soit le
chaos sur que nous bien sûr mais pour
que le vent ne pas pour ne pas répondre
à l'urgence sociale que nous menons dans
cette loi les personnes qui ont été je
veux dire condamné sur des actes
expressivement violents peuvent être
interdits peuvent être interdite par le
préfet de manifester mais je le rappelle
la personne peut faire appel au juge des
référés il a 48 heures pour le faire et
le juge des référés a 48 heures pour
répond en disant le préfet raison où le
préfet a tort et vous pouvez ou
gagnerait à la dame et miles kane
véritable donc quand on n'y a pas accès
à la justice bien sûr que si je veux
juste dire en donc les peines encourues
au cas où vous manifestiez de rien si
jamais la manifestation n'est pas
autorisé ces six mois de prison tout de
même et 7500 euros d'amendé
si vous arrivez avec un à un visage
dissimulé c'est un an de prison et 15000
euros d'amendé
vous en tant qu'homme de gauche ça vous
a posé aucun problème de conscience si
je ne pose pas de problème qu'on en soit
aujourd'hui à 200 millions de dégâts
payé par l'ensemble a laissé la
situation quand garinet
24% des français nous disent ça suffit
je parle pas du mouvement des gilet
jaune je parle pas des organisations
syndicales
j'étais syndiqués toute ma vie et j'ai
manifesté chaque fois que c'était n'est
nécessaire que jugée nécessaire je dis
simplement que ce qui est me semble
véritablement important c'est que les
ultra violent ceux qui s'attaquent à nos
forces de l'ordre de l'ordre ceux qui
font effectivement que aujourd'hui il ya
eu usage du lbd40 est un des usages de
deux grenades de désencerclement et qui
ont fait effectivement qu'il ya eu des
blessés et bien c'est cela effectivement
elle n'est pas liberticide et cette loi
liberticide contre les casseurs contre
les ultra violents contre les amitiés
contre ceux qui s'attaquent à la
république alors qu'est ce que vous avez
à répondre à sa richesse
moi je dirais que les casseurs ils sont
connus
les black blocks ce sont des
professionnels entre guillemets du cac
route du chaos et ils sont connus par
les forces de l'ordre
si on mettait les où il partage et là ma
société je termine si on mettait les
moyens qu'on met par exemple pour pour
dissoudre des cellules terroristes pour
se dissoudre ces éléments là l on
pourrait les arrêter en amont donc on ne
serait pas obligé de mettre des lois loi
après loi liberticide qui viennent
entacher le droit de manifester mais
qu'on mette les moyens au niveau d'aidé
de la police d'ailleurs je rappelle je
rappellerai quand même que le la case
des effectifs de la police du temps de
sarkozy n'a jamais été remise en cause
donc qu'on donne les moyens aux forces
de l'ordre pour faire le travail
non c'est donc dans cette impression sur
les effectifs c'est pas vrai dans
l'ancien monde a effectivement on a
renforcé mais simplement se séparer
c'est à dire que ce sarkozy en effet des
forces de l'ordre on diminue en ont et
après sous françois hollande où vous
étiez déjà député ps à l'assemblée
nationale vous dites que les effectifs
ont augmenté les villes qui photos
montées mais ce que nous vous les
connaissez faire vous pensez qu'ils me
dit monsieur kassai j'adhère à ce que
dit monsieur divers et dit si
effectivement on avait les moyens de les
arrêter c'est ce que prévoit la loi
c'est ce que prévoit cette loi c'est la
même qui a été utilisée globalement les
mêmes les mêmes sujets en ce qui
concernait les hooligans et ça a été
traité en plus sur cette loi
les choses sont claires il y aura un
bilan de ce qui aurait été fait le
gouvernement s'engage à remettre à
l'assemblée nationale effectivement le
bilan l'assemblée nationale si cette loi
je veux dire ne fonctionne pas elle sera
revue mais ce que vous dites
puisque on les connaît puisque on en
connaît un certain nombre ça va tout de
suite permettre
de leur interdire de manifester et
pourront faire appel parce que ils
pourront faire dans les 48 heures mais
ce que vous dites
arrêtons effectivement les gens qui
cassent elle est à terre disons-le et de
devenir sur une manifestation
ça sera le cas ça sera le cas là je
pensais que vous alliez en parler l'un
ou l'autre céline roy quand même
emmanuel macron le président de la
république a demandé au concile conseil
constitutionnel de se prononcer sur
cette loi vous en pensez quoi
sean n'ai pas d'avis là dessus
moi ce qui me fait doucement sourire
c'est quand monsieur barbier
je vous cite celui qui vient gasquet ou
masqué à une manifestation risque d'être
puni actuellement quand vous regardez
toutes les manifestations vous savez
très bien ça vous pouvez pas me dire que
c'est faux qu'il y a les équipes de
black blocks et il y a les gilets jaunes
même dans les gilets jaunes
les personnes viennent avec un masque
pour se protéger et des lunettes de
plongée
alors attention parce que même quand on
vit avec des lunettes de plongée on peut
finir en garde à vue on l'a vu donc ça
veut dire que au final cette loi elle
sert à quoi sert ni plus ni moins à
faire de la répression
et ça j'en suis sûre et certaine parce
que vous connaissez très bien les
blagues vous connaissez très bien léger
des jaune et gilet jaune qui font les
manifestations avec le climat où il ya
des milliers de personnes et ça se passe
hyper bien et quand vous voyez que
changer des visées sur ton fut hélas
vous dites attention celi gilet jaune et
on a parlé quand même un petit peu des
black box mais on a dû manifester
vannerie des jaunes
je ne crois pas qu'il ya eu un seul
incident si on en arrive à ce stade
maintenant c'est qu'il ya eu un gros des
failles man est un gros mépris du
gouvernement dont vous parce que vous
représentez quand même ça si monsieur
macro aurait donné tout de suite des
solutions à ce que le peuple crier parce
que là le peuple crie sa misère depuis
quatre mois c'est à ce moment là que la
violence arrivent vous tirez un enfant
type sur la jupe de sa mère pendant des
heures et des mois et sa mairie répond
pas legault citons par téléphone un
caprice c'est exactement ce qui se passe
maintenant nos vies on va faire répondre
monsieur barbier vous n'avez pas entendu
les gilet jaune voudrait bien vernement
ou de loin la majorité déjà premièrement
on a manifesté
je regrette monsieur d'hiver depuis
longtemps lui à la cgt - la cfdt
peut-être pas dans le même département
je vais jamais manifesté avec des
lunettes je veux dire de de ski et avec
un masque sur le visage n'est jamais si
jamais pascal que j'allais comme nestlé
a maintenant jallet pour revendiquer je
faisais est admiré revendications samedi
dernier il n'y avait plus de
revendications
quand on quand on en met cancon pis
trente deux cantons piquante au saccage
quand on met le feu à des bâtiments ce
ne sont plus des revendications la
région va demander comme à richard
divers par rapport au conseil
constitutionnel que le président de la
république en appelle à cette instance
supérieure pour dire est ce que cette
loi anti casseurs et constitutionnelles
ou pas vous en pensez quoi
ce que j'en pense c'est que le
gouvernement est en difficulté
actuellement
d'où ces ce renforcement de cet arsenal
répressif et coercitif et pourquoi parce
que le gouvernement et on l'a vu dans le
pseudo débat lancé par celui ci n'a
servi que de faire valoir à emmanuel
macron pour ré asseoir sa politique mais
à aucun moment il ya une volonté de
répondre à l'urgence sociale
j'en veux pour preuve que on continue
dans le même temps du que kylie a le
débat à avoir des lois qui tombe on
continue à casser le statut de la
fonction publique de supprimer des
fonctionnaires alors que les citoyens
demandent plus de service public
si vous supprimez ne font que des
fonctionnaires on ne pourra pas en des
services publics en nombre en face on
continue c'est à dire que ce ce débat si
vraiment il avait été un vrai des réels
débats il aurait dû permettre une trêve
on débat on amène un certain nombre de
choses
à l'issue du débat ont discuté solutions
apportées mais ce n'est pas le cas le
cas et que le gouvernement veut
continuer et que pour continuer il met
son art ce nom d'où l'intérêt
effectivement de pouvoir avoir de lancer
une négociation dès les premières
manifestations le gouvernement a demandé
effectivement pouvoir négocier personne
n'est venu autour de la table et on a
déjà partagé par contre je partage je
partage totalement sur le fait
effectivement et j'étais peut-être un
des premiers des députés effectivement
dans une tribune du monde au mois de
juillet l'an dernier alertée
gouvernement sur effectivement qu'ils
avaient besoin de plus de justice
sociale dans ce pays
c'est à la veille du congrès de
versailles que j'ai effectivement signé
cette tribune et je partage sur le fait
qu' on est allé vite sur un certain
nombre de choses et que derrière il ya
des gens qui ne se retrouvait pas dans
ce que nous avons réalisé des 10
milliards qui ont été mis
sur la table sur un certain nombre
effectivement dead qui était nécessaire
ya les sujets ainsi que les mesures qui
vont être prises et annoncées après
grand débat ça va continuer justement à
calmer tout le monde
en tout cas ce que je dis simplement
c'est qu'il faut effectivement qu'il y à
une négociation autour de ces mesures
est qu'il est plus que le temps de se
mettre autour de la table il aida ça
fait des années qu'ils se mettent autour
de la table avec qui sait visiblement
votre problème il baisse je vois des
gens qui étaient gilet jaune qui rentre
dans des partis politiques c'est bien
elle rentre maintenant à la grèce est
soumise parce que parce que derrière
d'autres sont rentrés dans d'autres
partis et parce que derrière
l'équipement il ya une nécessité
effectivement de pouvoir discuter
négocier et vais faire des avancées elle
est constatée les porter sur l'ensemble
aussi construit vous êtes prête a
construit alors moi je suis complètement
prêtes à construire sa ya aucun problème
là dessus quand vous parlez une
négociation
j'ai moi même rencontré madame barbe
arabe et ce ballon député de la haute
saône
tina chum apporté aucune réponse ben on
va pas on va pas dire du mal de
quelqu'un qui ont alors cédé à ben je ne
serai pas de malte et je m'en porte
juste ce que j'ai entendu et ce qui m'a
été dit elle m'a dit que toutes les
preuves les mesures que vous alliez
prendre donc ça c'était début novembre
ne serait effective dans trois ans vite
je vais être obligé de gérer été obligé
de vous interrompre parce qu'il
resterait très peu de temps dans dans
cette émission vous entre nous là on est
juste entre nous vous avez misé sur un
essoufflement du mouvement
et au bout de quatre mois vous vous
dites on est assez simple et non je
crois qu'à partir du moment où il ya du
moment il ya un grand débat qui est
lancé qui a promis la première fois que
ça se passe dans un pays qui a peut-être
et je l'espère un référendum derrière
sur un certain nombre de questions qui
seront posées
la première des choses qu'il fallait
faire et j'ai invite toujours les gilet
jaune à le faire c'est de dire
aujourd'hui rentrer dans la négociation
en négociation ce sera une négociation
ce sera la fin de du monde pour
aujourd'hui merci madame merci messieurs
bon dimanche après midi à tous au revoir
du bon gars
[Musique]